-(APPLAUSE)
-Okay, welcome to Overtime.
We have Professor of Marketing
at NYU Stern School of Business,
Scott Galloway.
Former Governor Andrew Cuomo's
top aide Melissa DeRosa.
Former governor of New York,
Andrew Cuomo.
-Okay, first question is...
-(APPLAUSE)
...for you.
"Is Trump right to think
that the cases that Alvin Bragg
and Tish James brought
against him are politically--"
-Okay. Well, there's a reversal.
-(MELISSA DEROSA LAUGHS)
Right. Because the same people--
Right.
Alvin Bragg, that's the one
about the hush money
-to Stormy Daniels, right?
-MELISSA: Right.
And Tish James is the one
about his business dealings.
Apparently, he's a crook.
(LAUGHTER)
"Is Trump right to think
those cases
are politically motivated?"
The, uh...
First, Trump is never right,
in my book. Just to--
-Just to start this off.
-(APPLAUSE)
BILL MAHER: Was there ever
a time when you were friends?
I mean, he goes way back
in New York as you do.
He goes way back.
We're both from Queens,
New York.
-Right, that's what I mean.
-Our families knew each other.
Uh, I dealt with him extensively
through COVID,
literally on a daily basis.
Uh. No, we were never friends.
-(LAUGHTER)
-BILL: Okay.
The-- What is interesting
about the question is the--
There was actually a poll.
Alvin Bragg,
the Manhattan district attorney
brought the first case
against Trump.
This is before Mar-a-Lago,
before January 6th,
which were, in my opinion,
frankly more serious cases.
But, they did a poll
after Alvin Bragg
brought the case.
Seventy-six percent
of Americans said
it was politically influenced.
Seventy-six percent.
Seventy-six percent of Americans
don't agree on the color
of the flag, right?
But 76 percent said
it was politically influenced.
And I think that
is telling, Bill,
because if-- if, uh,
we don't trust government,
we don't trust the media,
et cetera.
If this country believes
that the justice system itself
is then politically tainted,
then we have real trouble.
'Cause then you're on
the precipice of anarchy.
But that's what
I found telling about that.
It was more the public opinion
was so high
-that politics...
-BILL: Yeah.
...is influencing
the justice system.
And, I mean,
Trump is the kind of guy,
the more he goes to jail,
the more popular he becomes.
It's like-- It's street cred.
He's like a rapper.
(LAUGHTER)
-BILL: But it's true.
-It's true.
It's absolutely true.
And also, I never thought
they should have brought the--
the Stormy Daniels one.
And the fact that there's four.
One, it just--
To the people
who don't follow it closely,
you know,
they should have just had one--
one "he's generally
a piece of shit" trial.
(LAUGHTER)
But all--
One omnibus piece of shit...
-GPOS case. Yeah.
-Yeah. (LAUGHS)
MELISSA:
And the Stormy Daniels case...
The Stormy Daniels case,
it's like you're asking America
to then think of
this former porn star
-as a hero, and Michael Cohen...
-BILL: Right.
...who's a known liar and fixer,
as a hero,
and it was really
a books and records case
that was up-charged to beat
the statute of limitations.
So, yeah, it made it really easy
to roll your eyes
on the other ones
that were more serious.
The fear is that hush money,
or inflating your assets,
it does reduce the veracity
of much more serious crimes.
-BILL: Right.
-Including nuclear secrets,
and trying to overturn
the peaceful transfer of power.
I think it was just a tactical
error to go after the first two.
-BILL: Okay.
-ANDREW CUOMO: Here, here.
Melissa, "Is there a way
to make politics
less about personal vendettas,
and more about governing?"
Yeah, again that's why
I said at the beginning,
I see why you two were pissed,
because like, I mean,
Democrats at their best,
I think, are wonks.
And I mean that as
a great compliment.
It's the one thing
that Republicans, the--
You don't usually find
Republican wonks.
They're Reagan.
"Give me it on one page."
Bush.
"Give it to me on one page."
You know, they're one-pagers.
And that's--
Government is complicated.
And I know you two
put in the time.
Government is complicated,
and sometimes
it requires sharp elbows,
and sometimes it requires you
to have to be tough
in order to be effective.
But the thing I find
so funny about it is
in the reaction to my book,
some of it is people saying,
"Oh, this is--
You know, she wants to go out
and attack people
that attacked them."
And I'm like,
"Okay, well, there was a point
when you were comparing me
to Hitler's enabler,
but now we're like,
'Whoa, whoa, whoa,
don't criticize anybody. Don't,
you know, don't call this out.'"
And really,
what I find interesting,
is nobody wants to talk about
the facts of what happened,
'cause when you look at
it's so damning.
So it's easy to make it
about personalities
and about vendettas,
and about everything else.
Well, I feel like
those things carry the day.
To answer that question
I asked you at the beginning.
You know,
"Why would a liberal state
with a liberal paper
go after a liberal governor?"
Because, I'm sorry to make it
all about generations,
but a lot of
the younger generation
who was raised on the phone,
which makes you shady
and passive aggressive
and mean and fake.
I'm sorry, it just does.
-(LAUGHTER)
-I don't-- I don't think--
You think they care
about policy first and foremost?
I don't. I think they take glee
in this kind of shit.
They like taking--
Especially that nest of vipers
that's Albany.
Yeah. No, they love it.
It's sport. It's actual sport.
It's sport. It's always like,
"He's on my same team."
That's...
Who gives a shit whose team--
You know what? I'm on my team.
-And it's, you know, so-- so--
-(APPLAUSE)
Now, again,
I don't know what happened,
and I don't know who's at fault,
but I know there's two sides.
Okay, Scott,
"How can we prevent China
from using AI to sow chaos
and disrupt our elections?"
Well, we can't.
(LAUGHTER)
It's too late.
You're about to see an
AI misinformation lollapalooza
in Q1 and Q2 as Putin recognizes
the fastest blue line path
between him and victory
in Ukraine
is the re-election
of Donald Trump.
So if you're spending 70 billion
and 100,000 lives a year
fighting a losing war
in Ukraine,
wouldn't you be stupid
not to spend five or 10 billion
on Albanian troll farms,
A/B tested information,
and then an amoral
management team in social media
who will feel really bad
about the misinformation
the day after the election
when all the checks
have cleared?
We are about to see the
weaponization of media platforms
that have no fidelity
to the commonwealth,
and the GRU and AI
de-position Biden and Harris.
We're going to see
the first real externality
of mis-- of AI
in Q1 and Q2 of next year,
in terms of misinformation
around the election.
But Ozempic's
still more important?
-(LAUGHTER, APPLAUSE)
-I-- I-- I--
I still don't have the answer
to that question.
Okay.
Governor Cuomo,
"Knowing what you know now,
is there anything
you would change
about the way
you would administer--
administration handled COVID?"
Okay, that's the question
we didn't get to,
and I was gonna read you
the ProPublica statement.
Which-- They basically said
New York was the only state--
Now, of course, the scandal,
the issue involved,
if people don't remember,
is that, you know,
obviously this is
the beginning of the pandemic,
everything was chaotic,
we didn't know
what was going on.
But, uh, we did know this,
it mostly affected
the elderly people,
like most pathogens do.
They were the most vulnerable.
So, you allowed people
who had been in the hospital,
older people
from a nursing home,
now they go to the hospital,
to go back
into the nursing home
without testing them.
That pub-- ProPublica says
you were the only state to do it
without testing them
when they went back
into the nursing home.
And that's what caused
such death in the nursing homes.
-Yeah.
-Is that true?
No. Short answer is no.
Also, remember,
you say what we knew.
First, this
is Monday morning quarterbacking
by which I could make
the New York Jets champion,
right, if we're gonna do this.
The--
When COVID started, it was--
All the disinformation
was amazing, right?
It was coming from China,
wet market, zootrophic virus.
It was going to California
and the state of Washington.
So we banned travel
to-- to China-- from China.
It turned out that China
had already spread it to Europe.
All the European flights
were coming to New York, JFK.
So, it had been here for months,
and it was astronomical.
When we first found out
about it,
and Scott can appreciate this,
they were projecting we would
need 150,000 hospital beds
to deal with the number
of infected.
-I remember.
-We only had 50,000
in the entire state of New York.
-So we were--
-BILL: So you did it
to free up beds?
We were afraid
of losing hospital beds,
but people who were
in hospitals,
who were considered
medically stable,
who were tested,
were sent to nursing homes
if the nursing home said
they could treat that person
in a way that protects
the other people
in the nursing home.
And that was a way to make sure
-we had enough hospital--
-But it didn't, did it?
I mean, they also--
I mean, the same organization,
ProPublica,
says you counted the number
who died differently.
In other words,
you only counted the ones
who died in the nursing home.
Whereas many people came
from their nursing home
and died in the hospital,
and you didn't count those.
You only counted if they died
in the nursing home,
which they felt was deliberate.
Well, let me now get
weeds-y with you.
We got--
Every day I did a briefing.
And every day
we collected information
from the hospitals
and from nursing homes.
And we printed two numbers
on the screen every day.
This is the number of people
who died in a hospital,
this is the number of people
who died in a nursing home.
Which means you had to go back
every day to 1,000 hospitals,
nursing homes,
to collect this data.
And this how many died
in a hospital,
this is how many died
in a nursing home.
They then raised the question
and said, well,
"How many died in a hospital
who were originally
in a nursing home
before they went
to the hospital?"
That's a different question.
And that actually took
the state controller a year
to figure out and go back
and do the audit.
But, we said
this is how many died
in a nursing home,
in a hospital.
Different question.
"How many died in hospitals
who were originally
in nursing homes?"
You then have to
go back and forensically--
So you wouldn't do
anything differently?
-I mean, is it fair just--
-I would--
I would run that number now,
which nobody asked me for
until months later.
But it would have been--
You know,
this is in the middle of COVID,
and you're asking all these
people to do accounting.
But, if that's a number
that people would have
wound up wanting,
which they didn't say
for months, Bill,
I would have put that number
upfront in the beginning.
People died
in a lot of nursing homes
simply because
the people who take care
of the people
in the nursing homes are poor,
and the poor people get COVID.
But-- And it goes back
to incentives.
We have social media algorithms
that get more engagement
and more Nissan ads
if they call out people
and really make them look
as stupid
and as mean as possible.
I was on the board
of my kids' school during COVID.
I wanted
a harsher lockdown policy,
and in retrospect,
I was wrong.
The damage to kids of keeping
them out of school longer
was greater than the risk.
But here's the bottom line,
myself,
our great people at the CDC,
I'd like to think the governor,
we were all operating
with imperfect information,
and we were doing our best, so--
-It's-- It's-- Well...
-(APPLAUSE)
-So let's-- let's learn from it.
-BILL: But--
Let's learn from it.
Let's hold each other
accountable,
but let's bring a little bit
of grace and forgiveness
in the shit show that was COVID.
-(APPLAUSE)
-ANDREW: Yes.
But other states
did do it differently.
SCOTT GALLOWAY: Yeah.
I mean, I read Florida asked
for two negative COVID tests
before you could get back
into the nursing home.
The-- Look, if you want to--
First, on Scott's point,
he's exactly right.
All the early information
was wrong, as a matter of fact.
-BILL: A lot of it now is.
-Not just from President Trump,
Dr. Fauci,
who I have great respect for,
early on said this
is not going to be a problem.
They said it was--
You could contract it
from touching a surface.
We sprayed all the subways.
BILL:
I remember washing the mail.
-And we had--
-(LAUGHTER)
Yes. I still do, by the way.
(LAUGHTER)
But we had no idea
how infectious it was
for seniors versus children,
early on.
We had no idea.
We didn't know
if it was airborne,
if it was by touch.
So, this is--
And when I say
it's all hindsight now,
now you know, and the way--
Scott's exactly right.
You know how it got
into the nursing homes?
It got in months before
we knew it was here.
The staff walked it
into the nursing home.
BILL: Like I said,
the poor people.
-That's a lot of what it is.
-ANDREW: That's exactly
how it got in.
And also, I mean, it's a war.
In war, people die.
And generals...
(CLICKS TONGUE) ...it's not like
they're trying to kill them.
-But generals--
-MELISSA: No.
Generals have to make decisions.
Not all decisions
are the right decisions.
-You don't know until after.
-MELISSA: No.
And to that point, I mean,
when you ask the question,
"Would you
do things differently?"
I would do
everything differently.
-Every-- Literally everything.
-BILL: (LAUGHING) I agree.
There's nothing
I wouldn't do differently.
BILL: I never understand
these people in interviews
when they go, "Do you have
any regrets in life?"
-"No, I don't. No--" Like, what?
-(LAUGHTER)
-And that's why we have
to tell the story...
-Who-- Right.
...and we have to understand it,
because there will
be another pandemic,
and we've gotta learn
from this one,
so we do it better
the next time.
-All right, this is...
-(APPLAUSE)
We'll make this the last one.
This is for our
two New Yorkers here.
"What do you New Yorkers think
of how Mayor Eric Adams
and Governor Kathy..."
-"Hochul"? Uh, oh.
-(SIGHS) Yes.
-Yes, you pronounced it right.
-(LAUGHTER)
I take it you're a big fan.
"Have handled
the city's migrant crisis?"
Uh, I saw today,
they're offering
any of these migrants,
this sounds like a game show,
a plane trip
to anywhere in the world.
(LAUGHTER)
This policy,
you don't have to go home,
but you can't stay here.
You know, Ed Koch
started that in the '80s
to help solve the homeless
crisis in New York City.
He was giving out
one-way bus tickets
to the homeless population.
This is not new, but yes.
"See California,"
is what they said.
-(LAUGHTER)
-MELISSA: Yes. They did.
-Really, they did. It's true.
-(APPLAUSE)
So, what do you think about how
they handled the migrant crisis?
I-- You know, I just
wanna say something
in defense of Mayor Adams.
Immigration,
this migrant crisis,
is by definition
-a federal crisis.
-BILL: It is.
This happened
because of decisions made
by the Biden administration,
and they basically
made them unilaterally,
and then they didn't manage
any of it.
And so,
people started showing up.
The governor's not stepping in,
the president's not stepping in.
And so Eric Adams
is doing everything he can
to try to manage
this influx of people which--
the likes of which we haven't
seen since World War Two
-in New York City.
-BILL: Right.
He doesn't have
the money to do it.
the human resources to do it.
-BILL: Or the space.
-The space.
New York's crowded
to begin with.
Yeah. And then it's like
we have to turn around
and say thank you,
because the president's
offering to let us lease
Floyd Bennett Field,
where we can put people.
It's like, what?
You caused this problem,
and we're supposed
to say thank you
'cause you're freeing up a field
for us to build migrant beds?
It's just the craziest thing
in the world.
So, I mean, my heart goes out
to Eric Adams,
because he really was put
in a terrible position,
and nobody else is stepping up.
(APPLAUSE)
But didn't some of these places
sort of deserve it?
I'll ask you this, by saying,
"We're a sanctuary city."
Like, how these terrible
racist border states were worse.
And then,
when they called their bluff,
and sent the migrants to them,
they were like suddenly,
they weren't quite so liberal.
They're what I call
"liberal-in-theory" people.
A lot of people
are liberal in theory,
and when the migrants arrived,
they were like,
"Oh, what the fuck?"
-(LAUGHTER, APPLAUSE)
-Listen...
the sanctuary--
"Sanctuary city"
was used during Trump
when we were talking
about illegals.
New York City said
it was a sanctuary city.
New York State said
it was a sanctuary state.
Many other cities did also.
This is nothing
to do with sanctuary.
These people are here legally.
That's what we want to forget.
They're asylum seekers,
they are here legally
under the law.
-So, it's not about sanctuary.
-Well, they--
But, for the federal government
to abrogate its responsibility,
where we get to a point
where the Texas governor
is really deciding
where migrants go.
-Right.
-We'll send this to LA,
we'll send this.
New York City winds up
with 130,000,
and there's no federal oversight
or management.
And you give it to the one level
of local government
that is least able
to deal with it,
which is a city administration.
And then the state says,
you know,
"You're on your own."
It's crazy.
That's why I'm for
Dean Phillips for president.
(LAUGHTER, APPLAUSE)
All right, thank you, everybody.
Appreciate it.